welcome to the course my name is Gwen
and I'm a software developer here is the
itinerary for today part 1 we'll start
in the browser to get a feel for the
syntax and part 2 will be on a local
computer building apps as you regularly
would along the way we'll cover
different bits of the view API so you
can get started right away first let's
define what view is on a basic level
it's a front-end library to help you
build JavaScript applications now view
jeaious is more robust than something
like jQuery since it gives you specific
recommended patterns for code
organization although it did borrow a
lot of good ideas from jQuery angular
react and others it's usually not found
in the wild by itself you'll see it used
with lots of other libraries and
combined to make sort of a framework an
alternative to react angular and others
and we'll cover many of these libraries
today so let's get straight into it I'm
here my browser at jsfiddle dotnet is
just another place to put front-end code
and I'm going to try hello world so this
is if I was just writing a plain HTML or
jQuery application I might put something
like this so how do I attach this to the
view instance here I've reloaded the
view library so I can just choose it
from frameworks and extensions I'm just
pulling in the latest version and from
that library I have a view instance so I
can instantiate it like this and then
pass it an object of options the only
required option I have to set is element
so which element in the Dom do I want to
attach my view instance to I'm going to
attach it to root and then of course I
need to have a root an element with ID
of root here
so now my view instance is attached to
this div in the Dom if I run it of
course it doesn't do anything different
so let's make it do something different
there's also a data object I can use and
I can populate this with variables to
use in the Dom so I can say data
breeding now how do I put this in the
dome if you have something called double
mustache mustache syntax so anything
inside of this inside of these double
curly braces you looks at and will parse
as JavaScript so view comes down here
and says okay I have a variable in data
called greeting and so I'm going to
render the contents of the variable
we've run this again it changes the hell
of you another important concept in view
is data binding view uses two-way data
binding through a directive called Z
model on an input when I put V model it
binds it to a variable in the data
object that I give it so in this case
I'm telling you to bind this value of
the input to the greeting variable from
data if I run this everything inside of
my input is the same as the greeting
variable and then if I change it it live
updates extremely simple V model is
something called a directive there are a
lot of directives in view and they're
used to interact with the Dom let's look
at another common directive
v if v if evaluates an expression to a
boolean value either true or false so
let's start with something that we know
is true
so if one equals one
you're telling view to display this div
and render it to the page yep so this
isn't so useful it's usually used in
combination with data attributes here so
let's make a new data variable we're
gonna call it count
so if count equals one then display this
div to the screen so I'll put I change
this to count equals zero and of course
it won't display to the screen now there
are other directives that you can chain
called V else if and the else just like
an if-else statement so let me change
these
and let's save count equals two so this
is pretty self-explanatory if count is
one nope if count is to render this
anything out other than that render V
else Oh
put two it's gonna render red and so on
now the thing to note about V if these
divs if they're not true they don't get
rendered to the Dom at all now this
might be the behavior you want and many
times it is view also has another
directive called V show so let's call
this V show and we'll just do the same
thing if count run and it's green now
this time if count is two of course
nothing displays here but it's actually
still being rendered to the Dom just
with display:none set in the CSS so if
you look in here to kind of dig in but
you can see that there's a div with
green inside this are same div up here
and it's set to style display:none so
it's still in the Dom here and so
sometimes you want to use V if and
sometimes you want to use V show it
depends on what you're doing in the
application and if you need better
performance if you're constantly adding
and removing things from the Dom so
let's look at some more directives I've
already typed this out to save some
time is just an input with a submit
button you click it alerts and also an
email variable that is bound through the
v-model directive to the what's entered
into the input the view has this
directive called V blind of the bind can
take an HTML attribute like disabled
that works in vanilla HTML and parse it
as JavaScript so email button links will
say is less than two so what this does
is the regular HTML attribute disabled
would disable this button but we're
telling view to parse this as JavaScript
so we're gonna take the email length and
the button will be disabled only if the
email length is less than two if it's
greater than 2 then the button will be
enabled so let's run this and you can
see I can't click on it it's disabled
but if I type something here now it's
enabled again so you can do this on many
different attributes not just disabled
and there's also a shorthand which is
what you usually see in view
applications so it will be just whatever
HTML attribute preceded by a colon and
that shortcut for saying V bind colon
because it's so common in view now
another use for V bind that's common is
to dynamically add classes so let's do
colon the shorthand for V bind class and
then there's two different ways of doing
it I'm gonna start with the first syntax
which is called object syntax so I'm
going to dynamically add this read class
and I'm gonna say if the email dot
length is less than 2
I want to have a border a red border
around this input box so let me run that
and I have a red border and as soon as I
get past to where I get to or greater I
don't so that's how you can dynamically
toggle classes so there's another syntax
used if you want to toggle in between
two different classes which is array
syntax so we can use just a regular
JavaScript ternary here so you know
about length is let's say if it's less
than two then we're going to use the
class red and if it's greater than or
equal to two will be the class screen so
let me run this and we had the class red
and now it toggles back and forth in
between green there are several other
directives in view these are a bit less
common but I just want to mention some
of them so we already know that we can
put variables in the Dom using the
double mush deston mustache syntax if I
run this I can type and it shows up I
can actually do the same thing using a
directive called V text put paragraph
tag the text equals you know and then
just close the tag so if you're used to
jQuery you'll be used to the dot text
that it uses to put text inside of an
HTML element this is doing the exact
same thing so if I run this it does the
same thing as using double curly brace
there's also V HTML which will parse it
and we'll just put text inside but it
will parse it as HTML similar to the
HTML and jQuery so if I type stuff in it
does the exact same thing but I
also type in HTML tags and it parses it
as HTML so what if you want to render
something just once a static HTML
well view has another directive called V
once say once and put the email in here
just to compare I'm going to copy this
and put it outside of the one's so let
me start with something initially here
so as I update this it only changes in
the second one because it's frozen and
just set as the static HTML of whatever
it was initially the second one will
still display and update as you change
the v-model for that variable so let's
look at looping in view I'm just going
to clean this up real quick all of this
and let's make a list unordered list
it's no I and the directive to handle
looping in the Dom in view is called v4
so let me come down here and get
something to actually loop through which
is an array of cats I've already written
paste it there and the syntax for this
will be you need to take your red cats
and you're gonna say item in items so it
will just be like a four in loop in
JavaScript so you'll say cat in cats and
then during every iteration of the loop
you'll have access to the cat variable
which will be per index in the array so
I'm just gonna put cat here and run this
again and it comes out with all the
different cats in the array so of course
in the first iteration it displays in Li
element with the first cat inside which
is KitKat that index 0 and then it moves
the loop moves to index 1 and then index
2 and song is on and if you look in the
dev tools so you can see it has the full
array there now you can also do this
with objects of course these are just
simple objects with one key value pair
each so now cat would equal this object
with the name inside so to display the
cat's name now I'd have to do cat name
run it and I get all my cats
great so does more we can do with
looping and there's more we'll get to
later when we're looking at local
applications but that's pretty much how
it works so let's look at functions now
what if we wanted to add a new item to
this array so I'm just gonna add
something similar to what there was
before
and put the model little new cat and
button so I'll add a function to the
button in a second let me run this and
it renders my static HTML that's good
and let me add this new cat
so this is modeling my new cat that I'm
gonna add to this list so I need some
kind of a function to add it for me and
I can do that with a directive called V
on on click so when I click this button
I want it to perform an action in this
case I want it to run the function add
Kitty which we're about to make so the
data object is just for variables so to
put a function here I need to add one
called methods and this is another
object with functions inside so add
Kitty oops
kitty which is a function and I'm gonna
need to push a cat onto this array to
add it to this array so I can access any
any data variable inside of a method by
doing by using this so this dot cats
will access my cats array in data here
so this dot cats dot push and then I
want to push my new cat and my new cat I
also have access to on this so I can say
this dot new cat and I have the new cats
name and of course this would work if we
had just a plain array but we actually
have an array of objects so I'm gonna
put this inside of an object and then
say name is this dot new cat so this
will push another object onto this array
so let me see if this works
ran it let me add and I can't press
ENTER right now but when I click the
button it adds it pushes on to my array
perfect of course it's kind of annoying
click add every time so what if I want
it to respond to and enter as I'm typing
so I can quickly add more kiddies I can
actually add another event with V on
again but in this case I want V on key
up and then equals add kitty so I want
to run the function add Kitty on Kia so
let's run this and see what it does
so unfortunately though I didn't tell it
which key up so any key that I press
it's just adding a new cat for each one
which isn't the functionality that I
want so I can modify this key up by
saying key up dot enter let me run that
there key up enter so I have to hit
enter and it adds it to the array which
is perfect unfortunately it's not really
the functionality that we want to leave
the same cat in the input box so how do
we clear the input box we can just set
new cat this dot new cat equals an empty
string we've already pushed the new new
cat so we don't need it anymore and this
new cat is fine to be emptied again so
let's run this
there and now it empties ready for more
cats so there's many more events and
modifiers that you can chain on to
events for example view has an API for
chaining things on to the click event
you could do dot prevent which means
prevent default and you can also do stop
for stop propagation basically all of
the common things you might do that are
associated with that type of event which
is super useful I want to show one more
shortcut here and this is what you'll
normally see in a view application
instead of Veon because it's so commonly
used they have a shortcut to just do at
so at click and then you can do this
with any type of event anywhere you
would use beyond so you can say at KeyUp
let me just show that this still works
and it works fine both ways work this is
just adding a shortcut to it so let's
say you want to update something that's
rendering to the Dom view has something
called filters so I'm just going to
write a simple filter to illustrate what
it does and I'll come down here after
methods I can add another object and
this one is similar to methods it's an
object of functions and I'm going to put
the function capitalize function
actually value here and I'll return the
value but I'm going to change it to
upper case view will parse this as
JavaScript with cat name and then it
will pipe it to this capitalize function
which is a filter so it doesn't change
the actual value stored in the view
state here in the data property so all
of these names will still be lowercase
but just the display on the Dom will be
piped through this capitalize function
and it will come out value dot to
uppercase so if you run this so I
actually misspelled filters here I'm
gonna add an S and there you go it
filters through the capital I so you can
also pipe these so I'm going to add one
more key defi and I'll make another
filter here and I'll return the value Y
so when that it returns Y on the end if
I piped it the other way the Y would be
capitalized
really this isn't used that often in
view in my experience it's just a good
thing to know about for when the need
arises another set of methods in view
for updating what's seen on the Dom are
the computed methods so let me get rid
of filters real quick and this filters
block here and I'm gonna add computed
instead
and I'm going to use the same and scroll
down and I'm going to use the same
method so let's get a PHY the cat named
function this time the function doesn't
have to take anything so let's say if
this dot new cat which is our cat name
that's entered in in this input box so
if that the length of that is greater
than one I'm going to return this stop
cat name plus y and let's display this
in the Dom
to the fire game and I'll put a break
after so you probably noticed the
connection that view whenever it sees a
variable inside of the double curly
braces
it looks down here at the data property
and the methods and the filters and the
computed and tries to find a match for
it so let's run this there we go
and as I type well it's adding the Y for
computed but it's coming up with
undefined and that's because I
misspelled the variable so you put a new
cat there and run it again
yeah and that should work so later on
you'll be using computed a lot when you
deal with view X it's also extremely
useful if you have a lot of logic in the
Dom let's say you're doing a lot of
computation or updating inside of this
block then you could clean it up take
all of the logic outside of the Dom here
put it inside of a computed property and
then just display it in the Dom like
we're doing so let's say you want to
update something that's rendering to the
Dom view has something called filters so
I'm just going to write a simple filter
to illustrate what it does and I'll come
down here after methods I can add
another object and this one is similar
to methods it's an object of functions
and I'm going to put the function
capitalized function
actually value here and I'll return the
value but I'm going to change it to
upper case view will parse this as
JavaScript with cat name and then it
will pipe it to this capitalize function
which is a filter so it doesn't change
the actual value stored in the view
state here in the data property so all
of these names will still be lowercase
but just the display on the Dom will be
piped through this capitalize function
and it will come out value dot to
uppercase so if you run this so I
actually misspelled filters here I'm
going to add an S and there you go it
filters through the capital I so you can
also pipe these so I'm going to add one
more key defi and I'll make another
filter here Y so run that and it returns
Y on the end I piped it the other way
the Y would be capitalized
really this isn't used that often in
view in my experience it's just a good
thing to know about for when the need
arises let's talk about custom
components view has a component
architecture that lets you reuse bits of
code just like most modern single page
application frameworks so let's
illustrate this I'm going to create a
new component using view dot component
and I'm just gonna call it cat list and
then I pass it an object of options
that's it there's a template and I'm
just going to do a multi-line string
with let's say for right now and
actually a list should be inside of you
now how does this work
what's this I'll have to attach it to my
view instance so I'm gonna say component
and then give an array of components my
components name is cat list
now let's add cat list to the Dom so to
add any custom component that you make
you can just add it by its name and run
it and you can see cat down here you can
also pass in logic and variables so
let's pass in our cats array and display
the array through the component the way
to accept variables in a component is
through something called props I'm going
to pass in the cats array I'm going to
say props cats actually this
and I'm gonna pass in cats and then here
I can use a V 4 V 4 so here I actually
have to pass in cats so I'm passing in
cats but if you remember here I have to
add V bind for the shortcut which is
just a colon because if I don't add that
it's just going to treat cats as a
string when it gets passed into the
component instead of treating it as
JavaScript and then looking in the data
property and getting the array so now
cats is set to the array of cats and if
I run this again it's the same array and
it adds on to both of them so the idea
of having components is that they're
reusable modular pieces and when you're
developing view locally view CLI brie
it's a really nice project with you with
a modular architecture that kind of
handles this under the hood for you
to wrap up here I just want to talk
quickly about view lifecycle methods
view will trigger certain functions to
run which can be very useful when you're
developing an application so I have four
functions here created mounted updated
and destroyed and they're just logging
things I'm gonna run this
and if I look at the console it shows
created when the component is created
when it's mounted as it Adamic runs
mounted now it's been updated because
the state and the data object has been
updated now for destroyed it's a bit
harder because in the small applications
instance never leaves the Dahmer's
destroyed so I'm going to take a
function to call destroy so I'm
basically setting a timer for 5 seconds
and after 5 seconds it's going to call
app dot destroy because the view
instance is set equal to the app
variable so this will destroy it let me
run this again so I see created mounted
and then destroyed this also means I
won't be able to update anything here
because it will be just statically
render at HTML as it is it's no longer
connected to view there are many other
functions that run including before
mounted before destroyed and I think
they're very well drawn out in the view
documentation so view jeaious org the
version to guide and if you look at the
lifecycle diagram section it shows you
exactly when each function is going to
be run during the lifecycle of the
component so this is a really good
reference and you'll be using these a
lot as you develop applications next
we're going to go over how to start
developing applications with view CLI
locally
to create a view jeaious application
we're going to start with the command
line interface so if you come to CLI dot
view Jas org and click on getting
started now over here on the left is a
link for installation and it prompts you
to NPM install - G view CLI globally so
if you copy this command and come over
to your terminal you can enter this and
install view CLI I've already done this
so I'm just gonna check my version my
version is three point one point one so
now I'm going to create a view app I can
do this with the view create command so
view space create and then whatever I
want to name my application which in
this case I'm going to call it quiz so
it takes me through a series of prompts
mm-hm
so if you'll notice the last one
manually select so you can select
routing testing linting etc the default
gives you just babble and es lint and is
a pretty basic site on top this is a
template I created which I'm going to
talk about how to do later so for right
now we're just going to pick the default
to get started and see how it works it's
installing all the dependencies this
will take a few minutes and it creates a
folder for you called quiz with your
view application inside and now it also
tells me how to run the application so I
can move into the quiz folder npm run
serve and it's going to run my view
application on port 8080 i'm gonna copy
this go to my browser
and it gives me a boilerplate
application let's open up our
application and see the code I'm gonna
be opening up envious code which is a
free code editor and you can see by
default it gives you a few config files
package.json which is where you
reference all of the code that you
didn't write any third-party libraries
and then the meat of the application is
in the source directory and this is
where your j/s gets rendered or your
view gets rendered to the page so you
can see it's creating a new view
instance like we did before the syntax
is a little bit different but it's doing
the exact same thing it's mounting it to
a Dom element with the ID of app if
you're wondering where your HTML file is
it's in the public directory you can see
your index.html and view is doing quite
a few things under the hood that you
can't see so it auto injects your script
files so it creates a bundle out of your
main j/s and all of these different view
files it bundles them all together and
then it injects a script into your HTML
file for you that's one of the really
nice things about using view CLI you
have all of this boilerplate and setup
done for you like web pack and babel so
you can just start building right away
if you want to look at the view scripts
these are the different scripts that
view is calling to run your application
locally or to build it for production or
to lint it for you so let's look at the
application from the main j/s it's
importing this app view file which is
the entry point of the view application
if you look at app view you can see that
it puts a template this isn't created by
view this is part of the html5 standard
but it puts it in the same file with a
script tag and also a style tag how view
works is when you're building an
application locally you create many
different files each with their own
template tag containing your HTML and
then a script tag which contains the
JavaScript
interacts with that HTML so in that way
you can divide up your application into
components and then put them all
together they're all bundled into this
main.js surrendered to the page so
here's the first project we're going to
be building it's a quiz application that
keeps track of the number of total
questions you have answered and the
number you got correct the questions are
pulled in from an API and displayed
along with the answers the only user
actions are to select an answer
click Submit and you also have the
option of resetting the count of
questions to zero when you choose an
incorrect answer the color of the answer
will turn red once you hit submit and
the correct answer will turn green if
you get it correct it will only show the
correct answer that you selected back in
our quiz app let's start making
components first I'm going to delete
this hello world view which will not
need and create two new components
header view and question box top view
which is where we'll display the
question answers and the submit button
inside of components the only required
element is to have a template tag for
HTML you don't really need script tag or
a style tag so I'm just going to put
some dummy text in here
question box and I'm gonna copy this for
the header component and just put a
header here so the app component is
still expecting hello world so I'm gonna
put our new components in here instead
I'm gonna say header and header
to be able to use the component in the
template section I need to add header
here it's comma and then question box
and now I can get rid of the hello world
in image and I'm going to add the header
here as well as the question box all
right let me run this and p.m. run serve
and in the browser we can see we have
both components a header and question
box so before i update any of the
components anymore i'm gonna install a
third-party library called bootstrap
view bootstrap view has a lot of
built-in components and CSS already
written so we don't have to worry about
styling if you're interested to see more
you can go to their Docs or see all the
components that they offer like buttons
different form elements and they're
rather nice layout and grid system which
we will be using so to get started I'm
gonna go back get started and copy this
command it wants me to npm install view
bootstrap view and bootstrap so I only
need bootstrap view and bootstrap I'm
gonna go ahead and copy it go to my
terminal let me close this and get rid
of you alright now that that's installed
I can add it to my project in my main
JavaScript file I'm going to import view
and then call view use to add it to my
application so when you create view apps
using the view CLI this will be in the
main J's file you can add import
bootstrap view I like to do my relatives
Dependencies last and now I'm calling
view use bootstrap view of course this
view use is just for the JavaScript
portion of bootstrap so I'm also going
to take the CSS and import it let me
import bootstrap CSS and now I can start
using these built in bootstrap
components so let's use view bootstrap
in the header component I'm actually
going to go over to the view bootstrap
Docs and find the nav and the header is
not going to be a real nav in this
application but just for styling
purposes I'm going to go ahead and use
this I'm going to switch to two spaces
here for consistency put a wrapper div
in case I want to attach classes to it
later also now I only want two items in
here I want to have the name of the
application which would be something
like fancy quiz app and then a counter
for the number of correct versus total
questions so I'm just gonna hard code
this for right now and replace these
with variables once I have that part of
the app working so let me see how this
looks let's run the app again
and now oops now in the browser awesome
the only problem is these are links
because it thinks it's an overview
bootstrap thinks we're making a navbar
so I'm just going to go ahead and
disable these instead of active here I'm
gonna put disable and disabled and then
for the logo I just want to
differentiate the style a little bit so
I'm gonna make it bold also to offset
the header I'm just gonna add tabs here
and this should auto restart yeah this
auto starts in here so I'll go to my
browser tabs added this line here and
then I have my logo and the counter so
the header component is done for right
now let's move to the question box and
go ahead and get that set up
so the question box is going to use
another view bootstrap component called
the Jumbotron which is basically a page
element that sets itself out of the page
like this I'm actually gonna copy this
code with the enclosing div switch back
to my code editor and paste it here just
like before I want to have two spaces
indent here just to note I always like
to have this wrapper div around
components because I like to make
container classes for when I use sass or
CSS so I would put something like
question box container here and then
reference this class to style this whole
component so this is a pretty plain
Jumbotron you'll see it in our app and
it's not exactly what we want because we
want a question and then answers below
it so in the Jumbotron Doc's we can
actually use templates inside that will
make the component look more like this
so I can put the question on top then
list the answers and have the submit
button at the bottom
and the submit button is another view
bootstrap element for buttons
notice it's perfectly fine to have more
templates inside of the parent template
which is your component and you'll see
libraries doing this using something
called slots that we'll talk about later
but for right now I'm just going to copy
these go back to my component and I'm
gonna put this inside so let's see what
this looks like not too bad I am going
to remove the header because we already
have a logo on the page and we just need
to put the question here so this will be
our question and then our list of
answers will go somewhere here as well
as a submit button and a button once
you've submitted to navigate to the next
question let's see what that looks like
so we'll also have to get rid of these
which we don't want now let's see what
this one looks like perfect question
list of answers buttons now one more
thing I want to do in view bootstrap
before I get to the Java Script is set
up a grid to kind of prevent these
questions or the question box from going
fullscreen so layout and grid system see
the examples of how you can lay out a
page with different containers in rows
and columns for this I don't have
different rows so I'm just going to use
so I'm just going to use the basic one
here go back to my code editor and I'm
going to go to here and I want this to
wrap the question box component so get
rid of the extra two columns
enter and then just copy this paste and
then in this column I'm going to tell it
so on a small screen or anything larger
than a small screen I want to take up
half the page which is 6 because
bootstrap basically gives you 12
vertical columns so if you want half the
page you can do 6 offset offset equals 3
and let me show you what this is doing
so I'll inspect element here and the
jumbotron in the question box container
is taking up 6 columns so if I hover
over this you can kind of see that the
yellow part is a three column offset
from the left and the extra white
padding on the far left is from the
container so putting it inside a
bootstrap container just automatically
centers an element on the page and gives
it a little bit of padding on either
side so inside the container we have 12
columns we're using 6 and offsetting by
3 great now let's jump into the API for
the questions and start pulling some
actual data for the application open TD
be calm is a quiz API that we can pull
questions from they give you a lot of
nice options like you can browse through
questions you can submit your own
questions because these are all user
submitted questions and they also have a
pretty nice API by filling out this
information we can actually generate an
API URL to pull questions from so I
think pulling ten questions is good in
category I'm just going to select
animals difficulty any is fine any type
a multiple choice just so the UI is the
same for every question default encoding
is fine so now it generates me this API
URL I'm gonna go put it in my browser
and I
see every time I make a request to this
API it pulls ten questions about animals
I think one kind of confusing thing with
working with this API is that instead of
putting all of these in one array they
put the correct answer separate from all
of the incorrect answers which is fine
because we're just going to take the
correct answer with the incorrect
answers write a function to shuffle them
all together and then match up the
correct answer based off of what the
user selects and of course every time
you hit this API it's going to come up
with a different series of random
questions that it pulls let's put the
API in our application now so I'm in my
app component now and I'm just going to
add a function to pull in the questions
and answers from the API so if you
remember when we were in the browser
using jsfiddle we covered something
called lifecycle methods which are
functions that get called automatically
by view as components either get created
or mounted or destroyed etc so we're
going to use one called mounted here
function and in it we're going to use
the standard fetch API which is a web
standard and doesn't need a library to
be imported so I'm gonna paste our
questions API endpoint and then I'm
going to pass an object an options
object with the method I want to get
from this now that's all I really need
but I'm going to add a dot then and take
the response so I'm gonna say in the
response when you use an arrow function
here and say just let's console dot log
this response in JSON format alright
let's see what this does let's run this
by the way don't mind any of this orange
text that's just which get branch I'm on
and I'm trying to put different parts
this tutorial on different branches I'm
going to do and p.m. serve again no we
have an error I was just complaining
that I'm using a console dot log this
isn't a JavaScript errors on linting
error I'm actually gonna add this to my
package JSON and all of my linting can
fake is right here so I'm going to add
this as a rule here and say no console
try to remember this is just for demo
purposes if I were actually building an
application I would probably want to
have a warning or an error there just so
I would remember to remove all of those
extra console dot logs
anyways it's running now so I'm gonna
check it out in the browser of course
nothing is different right now but if I
look in the console refresh and I'm
actually getting a promise back which is
good it means I'm getting the data back
but we can't see it right now because I
have to update my promise chain so let
me go back to the code in app file I'm
just going to return this long JSON and
I'm going to change in chain another dot
then so I'll just say it's JSON data and
let me wrap this just so it's more clear
and then here is actually where I want
to be able to access the data from my
application so I'm going to create
doesn't look like a habit data method
yet so I'm going to create a data
function and a comma and I'm going to
return an object oops
object now if you notice this is a
little bit different from how we did it
in the browser the reason this is
different has to do with some more
complex features of JavaScript so we're
not going to talk about those
but it's basically required when you're
making this type of single page
application with a bunch of different
components that instead of just making a
data object you return an object from
within the data function so it's a minor
change so here I want to add a questions
array which will be empty at first and
can be populated from the questions from
the API so here I don't need to return
anything but I want to set the questions
this questions array to equal the
questions we get back from the API so
I'm going to set this top questions
equal to the data we get back from the
API dot results because if you remember
the API gives us back two things it
gives us a response code and then a
results array and the results array is
where all ten of the questions we are
pulling back are located I can save this
my app still running so I'll test it in
the browser and you can't see it yet so
to inspect the data on our components we
actually need something called Vijay s
dev tools so if you google view dev
tools this is the github repo if you
scroll down you can see they have a
Chrome extension a Firefox extension
which I'm using Firefox right now if
you're using something else or you just
want a standalone app that's fine too
they all have pretty much the same
functionality so I already have it
installed and it comes up on my dev
tools as view one of the things I love
about view is that it has all its dev
tools in one place we're gonna get into
view X and different things later some
other libraries you have different dev
tools for different things that you're
doing so under app I can see all of the
components imported into App the child
components I can also click on app and I
can see any data variables associated
with that component under questions I
can see I we have all ten questions that
we pulled from the API and it's in the
same format that the API showed us with
the incorrect answers and then the
single correct answer by itself so the
next step here
is to display the question to the screen
so let's go back to our code I'm back in
the app component and I want to be able
to display the question from this
question box component so I'm going to
have to pass it from the app component
to that one and I want to pass just the
question that we're on
so as you're clicking next through
questions I just want the question box
component to know about the current
question so I'm gonna keep in index of
the question here which will start at
zero and then view lets me pass data
variables and methods to my child
components by using V bind with custom
attributes so I can say the question I
want to pass equals my questions array
and the index so just the current
question that we're on and then
eventually we'll be able to click Next
and this index will increment so
question 1 question 2 etc now if you
remember the structure of our data off
of each question off of each question
so this is one question this object we
have the correct answer in correct
answer and the question so we have to
get the question text off by using dot
question so let's do that in the
question box so I'm going to come here
and remember the double mustache syntax
to use variables so I'm going to do
question which is passed from the
comparing component and then I have to
do dot question so maybe it would be
more clear if I did let me change this
to I guess current question make it more
clear and then I have to go and change
it in the parent component there so you
can give this any name but it's going to
be the same name in the child but that's
not the only thing in order for this
question to display properly in the
child component we not only have to
reference it in the HTML but we have to
pass it through the JavaScript so I'm
going to create a script tag here and a
regular exported object and for now I'm
just going to give it the key props
which is another object and I'll put the
current question which is also an object
datatype that I received from the parent
so any variables whether it's a data
property or a method that I'm passing
from app to question in order for it to
display in the HTML I have to reference
it in props and say hey I'm receiving
this particular named variable from the
parent and you reference it the same way
you would a data variable so you have
your component state which would be
local to this component in data so this
is local to the app dot view component
and then you can also have props which
is any variable passed from another
component to this component and you use
them the exact same way in the HTML so
let's see if this is working p.m. run
serve again so it built
I know let me check in my browser there
we go and it's showing one of my animal
questions the zero question I can check
this if I go down here into my view dev
tools I'm inspecting the question box
component and looking at the props I see
I get the current question object which
has the question a carnivorous animal
eats flesh the same thing we're seeing
on the screen and if I go to my app
component I can look at my index which
is zero so if I edit this and say one
then it actually changes the question
that I'm passing to the question box
component because now it's out the first
index instead of at the zero index so if
I go back to question box you can see
the question has changed so let's set up
the navigation between questions this
next button without having to go into
the view dev tools to change the index
back in my out dot view component after
data I'm going to create another object
called methods
and in here I want a method to increment
my index value too so I can navigate
through the questions so I'm going to
call it next as a function this is
basically a shorthand syntax for having
a key of next and a value as a function
but I can just write it like this in
JavaScript and in here the only thing I
want to do right now is take the index
which I can refer to as this dot index
in my method and increment it by 1 so
this dot index plus plus and that will
take the current value of this dot index
and data and add 1 to it every time the
next method is called so I'm also going
to want to pass the next method into the
question box so the same way I did with
current question I'm going to pass in
the next function and then go to
question box and receive it here in my
next button and just spread this out I'm
going to add an act click method and
then call the next function on click and
of course down here I have to receive
that prop so I'll say next which is also
a function so now when I click the next
button it should increment the value by
1 by calling the next function in app
dot view and then app dot view should
pass down the next question in the list
so let's see if this works view is still
running and let me go to the browser so
I have my zero index right now and
something's not working correctly it
says current question is undefined at
question box so let me go in here and
see it's still at index 0 of course
because we're getting an error and here
I have the next function and current
question so everything looks ok in our
data and I think we're not quite getting
the best
message so I'm gonna check in another
browser copy this go to Chrome and now I
can check in the chrome dev tools and
here it's saying cannot read property
question of undefined so let's go to the
question box component and see what it's
talking about
oops cuz look in question box it says
cannot read property question of
undefined so that means current question
is undefined but when we look at the dev
tools its defined so that means for a
brief moment when this component is
mounting it's still waiting for the data
to come from this component and we can
see that I'm just gonna add a life cycle
hook here and I'm just going to console
dot log this dot current question then
I'm back in the browser I'm gonna
refresh this and it's undefined but in
the dev tools it is defined so that
means right when the component mounts
it's still undefined and it's a moment
later when the questions come back from
the server and it goes into the state in
this component and then it gets passed
to the question box component so an easy
thing to do would be not to render the
question box component until these
questions are defined so wait until we
fetch the questions and save them in the
component state until we render this
component so I'm going to add a V if
directive and I'm going to say V if
questions
got length so if the array is empty then
the length will be zero which is a
falsie value so the question box won't
render but as soon as the questions come
back from the server the question length
will not be equal to 0 and so question
dot length will be truthy and question
box will render so let's see if this
fixes the error refresh let me go to the
console and now there's no error of
course we're still getting our lock but
it fixed the error because now for the
brief moment in time question Bacchus is
not rendering without the data available
to it and now we are able to also
navigate between questions just as we
would expect with the next function
incrementing the index of course there
are still problems because when the
index gets to 10 it'll throw an error
because that's passed the length of the
questions array and we'll fix that in a
minute
back in the question box component let's
add the list of answers here instead of
the dummy text so if you remember our
data structure had a list of the three
incorrect answers and then the correct
ones separately so to display all for
answers we just need to put the four
answers together so as a temporary
solution let's use a computed method so
I have an object of computed methods and
I'm gonna call it answers so I basically
have to take current question from props
and the array of incorrect answers and
I'm actually going to assign this to a
new array I'm gonna say let answers
equal current question incorrect answers
and what I'm doing here is making a copy
of the array instead of referencing the
same array and now I'm going to need to
take answers this
SURS array and append or push the
correct answer on to the end so I take
current question dot correct answer and
I push that onto the array and of course
this is the array that I want to return
so I'll just return that so I should
have all four of my answers in this
array now and for right now I'll just
replace it in here with a v4 so I'm
gonna do V 4 equals answer and answers
which is going to reference our computed
answers and here it's going to complain
because for any V for loop I'm going to
need a key attribute so view requires
this for accessing these elements in the
Dom so I can do a V bind key and usually
you want to do something unique here we
kind of know all of the answer or each
answer is going to be unique so each
paragraph tag that is created in this
for loop is going to have a unique key
which will be equal to the answer
usually if you're doing this in an
actual application you'll want to use
some kind of unique identifier or view
also gives you the option here of
getting the index in the array so you
could call it index and then use index
here as your unique identifier and I
guess I'll just leave it like that for
now now if we were to look at this right
now we would see four empty paragraph
tags so I'm gonna put the answer text
inside with double curly braces save
that now I'll test it in the browser go
here refresh looks like I'm getting an
error what error my getting seems like a
similar error to before I'm getting
current question is not defined Oh
so I actually referenced current
question incorrectly
if you look here I'm referencing current
question but that's assuming that it
would be an accessible variable actually
because it's a prop I need to access it
through this stock current question and
I'm gonna have to do this stock current
question about correct answer as well so
this should fix the problem and actually
anytime you want to access a prop or a
data variable in another function
whether it's a method or computed or
anything else you have to do this dot
the name of your variable so I'll save
that
see if that fixed it and yes it is fixed
these are just old error so I'll refresh
so it is fixed but we're getting just
the numbers of the answer and not the
answer text so there's actually another
mistake here and it was in how I
returned answers so I'm going to pre
push answers here push the correct
answer onto the array and now I will
return answers and that should fix the
problem yep
and now we're getting the correct
looping through our answers and they're
all for displaying if we go to the next
next next and it's displaying all their
answers now we actually want this to
look a bit more like a list and also
make it clickable for the users so I'm
gonna go to view bootstrap again
components bootstrap view and I'm gonna
go down to should be a list group here's
it here it is and we want to display it
like this this will make it easy for a
user to hover and click on an element so
this is pretty easy I'm just gonna copy
this list group here since this is
exactly what I want it to look like go
back to my code and I'm going to paste
the list group in here these tab them
over and I'll get rid of all except one
now I want the list group on the outside
and I want to loop through and make a
bunch of these items I'm gonna put this
on another line put this over format it
nice and now I can copy paste
the loop v4 loop and also copy this and
then put the answer inside instead of
the dummy text and that should work let
me save that and see how it looks in the
browser go here and it works just fine
so I don't really like how the buttons
and everything are rubbing up against
each other and then up against the
answers so if I look in my dev tools I
can refer to these with the classlist
group or list group item so I'm going to
copy this class go back to the
application and just add a style tag to
the bottom any view component can have a
style tag in it and there are different
options you can use for styling I'm just
going to use default CSS you can also
use sass if you want to I'm also going
to denote that these styles are scoped
meaning they won't be global Styles that
will only affect styling in this
component and I'm gonna paste the class
that I copied and say that for the list
group I want to have a margin it's a
margin bottom of 15 pixels save that see
how it looks and there's a little bit of
padding now for the buttons I'm gonna
put a sideways margin and I'm gonna
reference these as VTN from the button
class so I'll put margin I'll just make
the top and bottom zero and then left
and right maybe I'll give it five pixels
save that and now it looks a little bit
better spaced out so now to make the
buttons clickable let's go back to the
question box component
and I want to add an act click function
here so I click equals a new function
I'm going to create called select answer
and I'm actually going to pass it the
index of the answer that was selected
and I'll go down and create this
function under methods an object and
selected answer and then I'm just going
to log out the index here
let me test this in the browser see if
it works and it does so I have the
correct index of the answer I'm
selecting the next thing is to save the
select index on the component so I'm
going to create a function here
and return an object of our data
variables and the first one I'm going to
say is selected index and for right now
I'll just set it to null and now down
here in the selected index method I'm
going to say this dot selected index
equals index and we can see this in the
view dev tools go back to the browser
I'm gonna refresh go to the view dev
tools and in question box
I can see selected indexes no okay so I
tried refreshing and let me click again
and again and for some reason the state
here isn't updating but if I hit refresh
in my view dev tools then the state
updates to the correct number and now if
I click on this first one here and click
refresh now the State updates to zero so
for some reason the view dev tools
aren't updating but our function is
working correctly there are still a few
more steps to do to be able to get our
answers working correctly and first of
all there's no visual feedback to the
user to let them know to first click on
an answer or that they've selected an
answer so let's first create a hover
style and I'm going to go below here
copy this and say list group item hover
hover state so when the user hovers over
it I want to just change the background
color slightly right now the background
on the answers is white I believe so let
me change it to a shade of gray if ffff
is white maybe I'll do a EEE and see how
that looks now when you hover over it
you can see that it's a clickable item
another thing I should add is changing
the cursor to a pointer
and now when I hover I can see that I
have this little clickable hand
unfortunately when I click let me click
on Neanderthals and I still have to
refresh this it's selecting the index in
the data but the user has no feedback
here as to which answer they've selected
or if the application is even working so
let's fix this by adding selected
classes back in the code I'm gonna add
two more classes here one is for a
selected answer and I'm going to give
this background color let's just say
blue for right now background color of
blue and then a correct answer when the
answer is correct I'm going to give it a
background color of green and one more
when the answer is incorrect
I'll give it a background color of red
in order to add these classes into the
code we're going to use one of our data
variables selected index which should be
set to the user selected index when they
click on an answer and we need to add a
V bind property here and bind and bind a
CSS class to this so I'm going to put
class equals and then it's going to be
an array we're actually going to add
things to this later on but for right
now I'm just going to do selected index
if it equals index then I'm going to use
a ternary and I'm going to say let's
give it the class selected selected and
if it's not then we'll give it just an
empty string no class save this and then
in the browser
let me try selecting
and it's not quite working when we look
at the console if i refresh then it does
work unfortunately it's a really dark
ugly color so let's just change it to
maybe a light blue let me go down
selected could be light blue let's do
light green back in the browser no it
looks much better and then if you go
next of course it's not clearing the
answer which is another bug we're gonna
have to fix a second bug is that our
answers aren't shuffled so we actually
know that every fourth answer here is
the correct one and then on top of that
our submit button doesn't do anything
yet so let's go back to the code and fix
these three things starting with the
answer shuffling to shuffle the answers
for every single time that the question
changes I'm going to add something
called a watch method here it's just
like computed or methods in that it
takes an object of functions and in this
object I can watch for changes to my
props it will run this function when it
changes so I'm actually going to give it
the same name as my current question
prop and then when the current question
changes from the parent it's going to
run this function where we will shuffle
our answers every time so the first
thing I want to do in the function is to
set this dot selected index back to null
every time the question changes and then
I want to shuffle the answers that
shuffle answers and shuffle answers is
going to be another method that I create
here and I'm going to copy paste this
answers array I was creating there and
here I'm going to put the
the current question dot correct answer
so I have them all in an array all four
answers now I could do this with a for
loop and some randomization but there's
actually a really nice helper library
that I can use for this to help me
shuffle an array and it's called low -
low - is a very popular JavaScript
library that's full of useful utilities
that might take you a while to write on
your own and that are common in many
projects like having to shuffle an array
so I'm going to go to the low - github
and right now we're just going to do NPM
Eylau - in the terminal well that's
installing I'm going to go back to the
browser and we're going to be using a
function called shuffle
in the root of the low - github repo you
can see that every single utility
function in the low - library is listed
here as its own file so I can actually
go into shuffle j/s and see exactly how
it works what algorithm they're using
for the shuffle and if I wanted to I
could just borrow this one file and any
files that it imports instead of
importing the whole lodash library I
think it's really nicely laid out in
this fashion and it's a very good
learning experience if you want to look
through some well written algorithms in
JavaScript so it should be done
installing let me go back to my server
and p.m. run serve
and now back in my code I'm going to add
the lodash library
I need another data property where I'm
gonna put shuffled answers this is going
to be an array and I'm just gonna call
it shuffled answers and here I'll put
this dot shuffled answers equals now
lodash the convention is to import it
with an underscore and then use it
instead of calling lodash dot shuffle I
would import it as an underscore here
and so I'm going to do that at the top
of the script file say import underscore
from lodash actually get rid of this
mounted function and I need to tell it
what array I want shuffled which in this
case is the answers array so I do have a
typo here instead of saying current
question I'm saying correct question I'm
just gonna fix that now if I look at the
browser then I'm going to refresh and
let's take a look so right now we don't
have any shuffle dancers let's see if
when we hit next we actually get
shuffled answers which you can see bird
is the first element of the array at the
zero index in the regular answers where
we're just appending the correct answer
onto the end and then in the shuffled
answers bird is the at the second index
so we can see shuffling works
unfortunately it only works as we click
through the questions also we can check
and see that selection works and then it
does reset after we click for the next
question which is good now how do we get
it to shuffle on the first question
there are actually two ways we can do
this let me go back to the code and the
first way is something that you already
know we can add a mounted life-cycle
hook just like we had before and then we
could call this dot
full answers from here and that would
work that with shuffle answers on the
first component mount and then every
time after that when the current
question is updated in props it would
shuffle the answers which is fine it
gets the same functionality but there's
also another way that might be a little
bit better so I'm just going to show you
in these watch functions instead of
making them a function you can make it
an object and set some options on the
object so I'm just going to comment this
out real quick and set it to an object
and one of the options we have is to set
immediate to true and then we can add a
handler oops which is another function
and then inside of this handler function
we can do the same things we were doing
before and it will be called like a
regular watch function get rid of this
and now let's see if it does in fact
update and shuffle the questions for the
first question that is shown back in the
browser
I'm going to refresh
and then check and see if they are
shuffled and yes this is great we do
have shuffle dancers now so just to
reiterate what immediate does is instead
of only running this watch function when
current question updates it's going to
also run it when current question first
gets passed as props and then every
subsequent time that it updates it will
also run the handler function again here
I'm going to update the submit button
I'm going to clean it up a little bit
first
take away this href that we're not going
to use and then put it on separate lines
because we're going to add a couple more
things here for right now if you
remember there's the the on directive
which I can attach to events I click so
V on click and then I want to run a
function that I'm going to create called
submit answer and here I'm going to
change this directive to use the
shortcut and now let's create the
function submit answer here down in our
methods answer and this will run
whenever that button is clicked and the
first thing we want to do is store
whether or not the answer is correct so
I'm going to create a variable and by
default I'm going to set it to false and
then if the user got the correct answer
I'll set it to true so if this dot
selected index equals the correct index
meaning they got the correct answer then
I'm going to set is correct to true and
what this is is correct variable I need
to be able to tell the app component
whether or not the user got it correct
and also let the app component know that
the answer was submitted because in the
header we have a counter of the correct
answers versus the total answers and
this information will have to come from
question box
through the app component and past as
props to the header so let me create a
new prop from the app and it's going to
be this dot increment and I'm going to
pass whether or not the user got the
answer correct
so is correct and I'm going to go ahead
and add this as a prop here its
increment is going to be a function and
now from the parent component I need to
actually add this function so let me go
ahead and pass it down and I have to
create the function in methods add the
increment function with the is correct
boolean and here I need to keep track of
two things the number of total user
submissions for answers and also the
total number that are correct so first
I'm going to check if it's correct so if
is correct I'm going to increment a new
data variable for the number of correct
so up here in data I'll go ahead and add
these so let's say the number of correct
answers set to zero and the number of
total answers that the user has answered
also set to zero to start and down here
I can say the number of correct
increment that number by one and then
the number of total I'll also increment
that number by one and I forgot that
this here so this dot number correct
increment by one this that total
increment by one and I want to do one
more thing here and that's passed these
two values to the header component to
use so I'll add it here I'll use V bind
and pass the number of
recked and also then um total now in the
header to receive these props I'm going
to create the script tag script and
export an object with props and I'm
going to do props as an array this time
just to have both different ways and I'm
receiving the number correct answers
from the parent as well as the number of
total answers and I can put them here
with double curly braces so the number
of correct out of the number of total
now we changed a lot of things let's
look in the browser and see if this
works
let's see what it's complaining about it
seems to be okay right now I'm gonna
select an answer
click Submit click Next now I wonder why
it's not incrementing correct total and
it seems to only be incrementing the
number of correct
so let's look back in the code and see
why the total number is not incrementing
so we have sinem total as props that
should be fine
let's look an app and I'm total is
getting past you have none total here
and here I'm just doing total so I'm
going to put total and that should fix
the problem
I mean refresh just in case click on an
answer submit and now my num total is
incrementing though we shouldn't be able
to submit a question more than once
because right now there's nothing
stopping us from continuously submitting
or even submitting before we have
selected anything so really we should be
disabling the submit button and totally
make a selection so let's go ahead and
do that and I want it to set as disabled
if they have not answered the question
yet so I'm going to do V bind and then
the HTML attribute of disabled and I
want this to be true if they haven't
answered the question yet and false if
they have already answered it and then
the button will work so I can use one of
our data variables selected index
because it will be null until they've
selected an answer so I'm going to say
selected index equals null and let's
look in the browser and see if that
works now so it is disabled I can't
click on it right now
but when I select an answer it gets
brighter darker
and now when I hover over it you can see
the hand and now it selects correctly
and if I scroll up it will still be
incrementing two out of seven great now
let's work on not being able to submit
the answer multiple times like we can
right now what we are doing here just
checking if the selected index is null
only accounts for the case where the
user has not answered the question yet
so we're going to have to add another
check to see if the question has already
been answered and if it has then also
disabled this so I'm going to add
another data variable called just
answered and set this equal to false
and then up here I'm gonna say and
answered so as long as both of these
conditions are met and now I'm going to
have to add these to some functions down
here in the submit answer function I
want to set this dot is or this dot
answered equal to true because they've
already answered the question if this
function is running and then in my watch
handler I also want to reset this dot
answered as false for every question I
think actually in the button
I think I'm actually going to have to do
in or here so if it's null I haven't
selected an answer at all or if it
already has been answered in either one
of these cases it should be disabled let
me save that and then go to the browser
just refresh and then see my button is
disabled it's probably not a very good
color for a disabled button oh well and
now it's enabled and now I submit and
now it's disabled again after I submit
and it counted up and I got the
incorrect answer now it would be kind of
nice to see which one is the correct
answer because I know I got an incorrect
because of this counter but I don't
really know which one of the other three
was the correct answer and I can't
submit it again so let's change that in
the styles
jumping back into the code let's store
the correct answer I scroll down to my
data I'm going to add another variable
called correct index and I'll set that
equal to null initially and now when I
shuffle my answers meaning when I get a
new question I'm going to store which
one of the answers is correct I'll go
down to my shuffle answers function and
I'll say this dot correct index equals
this dot shuffled shuffled answers
inside the shuffled answers array I want
to get the index of the correct answer
after its shuffled so I'm going to use
the JavaScript property index of on the
array and then I'm going to say it's the
index of whatever the correct answer is
so I already have the correct answer
stored in this dot current question dot
correct answer so now this should keep
the correct answer so we still know it
even though all the answers are shuffled
together so let's see if this is working
go to the browser
pretty fresh now look at my question box
and I have hmm
well that's interesting I must have made
a mistake in typing this out let me go
and check the code and see what I did I
actually misspelled shuffled answers I
left off the S so now I'm gonna save
this go back to the browser again and it
shows the correct index let me go to the
next question and the correct index
changes per question unfortunately as a
user how do I know if what I selected
was correct there's no way for me to
know it just moves on to the next
question so let's add some functionality
and styling so the user can see feedback
that the answer is correct or not and in
doing this we'll need to make the submit
button work as well if you remember a
while back we made these different CSS
classes selected correct and incorrect
and so far we've only used the first one
so let's use the other two we show the
correct answer as green after they hit
submit and if they selected the
incorrect answer then that's going to
turn from light blue to red so we're
actually going to make a dynamic class
and here I'm going to put this on a
separate line because I'm going to be
adding some stuff just for the time
being here
we actually only want this selected
class to appear if the question is not
yet answered so I'm going to add a not
answered here and selected index and
just for a second I'm going to be
nesting turnery statements here and then
I'll clean it up after so right now we
have the case where it's not answered
and they've selected a choice so what
about if that case is not correct so
here I'm going to add a case if it's
answered and the correct index equals
index in that case they got it correct
we want to show it as correct and I
believe that's the name of our class
here yeah correct and otherwise we can
show it as nothing so let me save that
and see how it's working so far
yep so that's the correct answer and now
it shows the correct answer there
so there's gonna be another case that we
have to add here after here so I'm gonna
copy this actually and if it's not equal
to index I'm gonna say we're going to
use the incorrect class otherwise note
class so if it's answered and they
didn't get the correct answer then I
want it to turn red so let's see if that
works
obviously it didn't work that well
because every incorrect answer is
turning red and I just want the user
selected one to turn red so back in the
code I'm going to have to add one more
check into this chain and that will be
if selected index equals index and this
is getting kind of long and back in the
browser
I mean refresh there and now it
correctly shows of course this logic
that I wrote is kind of out of hand
and it's definitely messy to do all of
this inside of a class just to clean
this up we're going to move all of all
of these nested Turner ease into a
method and we'll call that method answer
class and we'll pass it the index each
list group item that's created so each
answer is going to call this method in
order to see what class it's going to
have so I'll go down to methods and add
this one onto the end answer class it's
going to be passed the index of the
answer and then just for reference these
are all the nested Turner ease I had up
there I'm gonna copy the first one and
first I need to create a variable called
answer class and set that equal to an
empty string I have an if statement so
if it's not answered but they've
selected an answer then I'm going to set
answer class equal to selected and I'll
just change some else ifs here and if
it's answered and they got the or the
answer is the correct answer
then the class for that particular
answer is going to be correct and then a
final case is if the user answered the
question but they got it incorrect and
we want to make that read with the
incorrect class so it would be answer
class equals incorrect and then down
here I'm gonna return answer class let
me clean this up and let's see if that
still works yes so the answered is not
defined and that's because again I
forgot to put this dot answered so
remember in the template you can use any
of these variables but if you're
referencing them in the JavaScript you
have to reference them as this dot so
this dot correct answer this dot
answered and this style selected index
and this dot correct index so this is
kind of long I'm going to put this on a
few lines
and that should work so let me try it in
the browser again seems to be working
it's selected correctly now I can submit
and I got it wrong so it's red and green
try one more question
I submit yep it works perfectly our
counter is still working this is the
whole quiz application the github code
will be linked below if you want to take
a look and you can see that there are
different branches so you could look at
different parts of the tutorial in
different stages if you wanted to
now we're going to build an app that's
slightly more complicated to demonstrate
how view routing and view X which is
view state management system work it's
going to be a basic four screen
application it's theme is getting cats
and dogs to be adopted and we're going
to be performing basic crud operations
to get used to state management now
there's a home screen two screens one
for cats and one for dogs and then you
can click on any animal name either cat
or dog and it will load a screen just
for that animal so here in the terminal
I'm going to create another view
application using view create and I'm
going to call it adopt pets now if you
remember last time we use the default
boilerplate this time we're going to
manually select features to manually
select you can go up and down with the
arrow keys and press spacebar such as
here I want to select router so I press
spacebar I also want view X if I wanted
to use SAS or something I would select
this one and then I think I'm gonna
leave testing out of this particular
application so that's all I want I'm
gonna hit enter
and then it asks me a few other
questions history mode for router is
literally a one-line change in the
router and I'm going to show you how
that works later for right now I'm just
gonna put yes I'm gonna pick SAS since
it's the most popular CSS preprocessor
and I want to show you how I include it
my applications for this I'm just gonna
put standard config although prettier
and airbnb have some nice features as
well either way all of these are just
templates and starting points so you can
always modify any rules that any of
these set for you I'm just gonna have it
run linting every time I save a file and
this is a personal preference of mine I
like to have my configuration in their
own files such as my unit testing config
Babel config or my es lint file by
itself instead of cluttering up the
package.json that can get pretty
unwieldy now if I want to save it as a
preset
for future projects I can click I can
type Y and it's going to ask me to give
it a name I'm just gonna type no here
and then show you the one I already have
and now it takes a few minutes to build
the project great it's done installing
I'm going to go into the adopt pets
directory and open this in vs code this
is very similar to the project last time
still have the index.html in public a
few differences here are that in the
main j/s instead of only rendering the
app we're setting our store for view X
as well as our view router configuration
in our view options another difference
is you'll notice that here we have a
views directory and a components
directory now if you look in the router
you'll notice that home and about which
are the two routes are both views so
these are the pages of your applications
which are connected to the router and
components are imported into the views
or into each other so if I look in home
I can see it's importing the hello world
component hello world up view and it's
displaying it to the Dom the idea is
that components are reusable pieces and
each page stands alone as a distinct
view in your application now if I go
back to the router there's a lot of
things you can do such as lazy loading
or even using multiple components here
but I'm going to keep it simple for now
so I'm gonna take this out of here and
import and now I can set component to
just about and get rid of all these
comments and now it's and it renders
exactly the same it's just a bit easier
to read right now now the store I'm just
gonna give a quick overview and I'll go
in deeper you're basically creating a
new view X store which is a global
object so any
functions or variables data anything
that you want to use maybe in multiple
parts of your application you can store
them all here and then import them into
whatever component you want and it's
like a global object for your
application the first thing I want to do
in this app is create the four pages and
link them together if I look in views I
have about at home I'm gonna go ahead
and leave the home component and delete
the about one and then create one called
Kats top view dogs that view
and the other one I'm just going to call
pet dot view and I'll put a boilerplate
template here and I'll do the same thing
for dogs put just the template here and
one for the pet page and now I'm going
to hook these up to the router
now I've defined all four routes that
I'm going to use in this application I'm
going to update my app file to link to
all four of those pages instead of just
home and about duplicate those and now
put cats dogs and the pet page which
eventually is going to be linked through
these two pages but I'll just leave it
for now
dogs and cats and let's see how that
looks
okay it has all of the links here you
can go to the different pages I'm just
gonna add this pipe in between copy this
there looks much better now let me get
rid of all this extra stuff on that page
which is in the home component importing
hello world and using this image I'm
just going to get rid of both of these
and just say home get rid of this and
this and now I'll delete the hello world
component perfect now just like before I
want to import view bootstrap to help do
the styling for me and lay out the pages
I'm gonna go to the browser view
bootstrap get started and install it
with NPM so stop my server and NPM I
bootstrap view now back in my browser I
can copy the import of view use
and I'll put it in my main.js file I'll
put it up here with my other library
imports and since I don't have a section
for views I'll put it right there now I
need to import the CSS as well so I'll
go and grab these links and put them
here and that's it now that I'm
importing view bootstrap I'm going to
use some of their table components to
display the tables of cats and dogs so
if I scroll down here see they have
table and this table looks fine to me so
I'm going to copy this be table and save
it and go back to my code and let me
close some of these now let me start
with cats and here I'm going to add that
table component and now of course I need
the data so I'll add a script tag and
close it and export default this object
data function and return an object and
now back in the browser you can see I
need an array of objects which I already
have in another file and I'm just going
to copy paste that into my application
so I'll create another folder in source
and I'm just going to call it data and
in data I'm gonna make two files one
file cats dot J s and the other one will
be dogs dot J s and I'm gonna copy and
paste data that I already have here here
are my dogs this is an array of dogs so
I'll do export
default this array and I have some
different information and metadata about
the dogs and make close this one and now
I'll add my cats which is also a very
similar array I'm gonna add them here
and now back in my cat's top view I'm
going to import cats from pet data /
cats
now this @ symbol is a shortcut that
view CLI sets up for you and it's a
reference to the source directory so
that way you don't have to do things
like dot dot slash dot dot slash dot and
whatnot so I'm just going to use the
shortcut at and now I'm going to return
cats here so this is the same if you
don't know the shortcut this is the same
as setting a cat's value equal to this
cats array that we're importing but the
shorthand is just to do it like this
since they both have the same name so
now for items I'm going to say cats here
and I'll see how that looks in the
browser back in Firefox if I go to adopt
pets and refresh I must have stopped my
server let me look back at item and yes
I did
so let me run npm run serve again great
my browser
all right it's working and now I have a
cats table showing all of my cats I'm
just going to clean this up a little bit
so it doesn't go all the way to the
edges of the page here
and I'm going to add a be container in
my app top view so for this router link
I'm going to wrap it in B container
which is another bootstrap component
provided by view bootstrap and I'll go
back to the browser refresh and that
looks much better as far as the width I
also need a page title so let me create
that real quick back in cats I'm going
to have an h1 here and say this is just
cats for adoption
alright that's good not too fancy but
looks fine now I'm going to copy paste
this and do the same thing for the dog's
tab and I'll go back here go to dogs I'm
gonna copy paste this table and the
script tag and then I just need to
change it to dogs
here's well and here great so those two
pages are looking good just to finish up
the home page I'm going to change this
to an h1 as well and I'm going to say
adopt new best friend h1 so that's all
of the nitty-gritty out of the way now
if I go back to my browser you can see
that I have these three pages but this
page is supposed to be that of an
individual cat or dog kind of like
seeing his individual profile so if I go
to cats for example then the pet page
should be something like cat slash one
for the ID of that cat so let's learn
how to do this through the view router
view router has something called dynamic
route matching what it does instead of
hard-coding the whole route you actually
have a dynamic route variable as part of
the route it's preceded by a colon and
then you can call the variable whatever
you'd like and then you can access this
variable when you go to that route in
the component associated with the route
on the route params object so let's see
what this would look like in our pet
component first I'm going to update the
router and say here under pets I'm going
to change it to be plural pets and slash
ID for the pet ID and I'm going to leave
these as they are for right now now let
me get rid of the link in the app dot
view file to pets let me just get rid of
that and now we need our table
components to have links to the pets
page for every item so we'll have to
update this table since right now it's
kind of a black box and we're passing in
this array of cats to a third-party
bootstrap component so let's go to the
bootstrap Docs and see how we can turn
each cat in the table into a
to that page I'll go to the browser and
I'm still under the bootstrap component
tables this whole page is pretty big so
I've skipped down to this format or call
back and basically what it allows you to
do is pass in a template with a dynamic
href so let's copy this and go back to
the code I'm gonna expand this close it
here and put this inside now I want to
mention something about slots because
you're probably going to see this a lot
in view especially if you are using
third-party libraries like via bootstrap
or if you are creating your own
components for someone else to use now
in bootstraps be table component it's
going to look something like
my formatter doesn't like this very much
so it's gonna look like template and
then have something exactly like what we
have with maybe a div inside and it's
going to have a bunch of other tags and
it will have this similar slot so
bootstrap is basically telling the
component where to put things that we
pass in to the this.b table so it has
different slots inside and if it has
multiple slots which in this case it
does it will say name equals name which
will be dynamic because we have lots of
different columns that could vary in the
table so bootstrap will have a slot for
each of our columns and that's how we
can pass it in here if you want to know
more about slots they're pretty easy and
they're described really well in the
view documentation and here I'm just
gonna replace this with slash pets slash
variable data dot value and I'm going to
change this to a router link not using a
tag to router link and I've got a link
here do link you can use an a tag I
think it's a little better and more
consistent to use a router link so let
me go to the browser and refresh and now
I have links for all of these now I
don't really want it to have the pet's
name
I want the ID so let me go back and
change it and instead of data dot value
which will give me the name of the pet
I'm gonna do data dot index which will
give me the index of the row in the
array so let me go back to the browser
and try this and now if I let me go home
now if I go and hover over it I can see
the link gives me the index and if I go
here you can see in the URL I've pet
slash is zero which is the ID of the pet
in the
so now I want to populate this page with
the details on the individual pet so
what I could do is take these pets
arrays and import them into my pet
component and then get the index off of
the router variable and just look in the
array in this component but I'm actually
going to put all of the pets dogs and
cats in state and then pull the pet I
want from State so let me go to the
store and this is a very small project
so I don't need to do this but I just
want to show you how I generally set
this up I make a new folder called store
and in store I make a separate file for
everything so I'll have a file for state
J s and one for mutations J s and then
one for actions jeaious and now I'll
make an index file to tie these together
index J s and I'm going to take what's
in store right now take all of this copy
it put it in the index file and now I'm
going to import the other three files so
import state from state report mutations
from mutations import actions from
actions and now I can use the shortcut
here and here
oops this object and get rid of that and
now of course I need these to be actual
objects in each file
I'll just for some of these export a
blank object for now the same thing in
mutations save this save this and now in
state I'll have a blank object but I'm
also going to be importing the
cat-and-dog data so I'm going to import
cats from puppet directory data slash
cats and I'll do the same thing for dogs
oops dogs and dogs and now on state now
this object is the default state of my
application so it's the data that I'm
going to be able to pull into any
component that I want so for right now I
will have these separate I'm going to do
cats and dogs as separate arrays on my
state and now what I can do with this is
go into my cats top view and instead of
importing cats from here I'm actually
going to import something from view X
called map state from view X and down
here I'm going to use a computed object
computed and the syntax for map state is
to use a spread operator and call the
function and pass it an array of the
items on state you would like to be able
to access from this component so here I
want to access cats from state so I
won't actually need this in my data
anymore
and I'm gonna get rid of it so now I can
get it directly from my view X store
I'll get this array
so let me go to the browser make sure
that's working
go home refresh now let me go to cats
and it's not working so I must have an
error let me see what error I have none
here let me go to the terminal now that
looks good so let's check the dev tools
and see if we have a problem with our
data there and in my view dev tools I
can see cats is undefined
so let me see why it's undefined if I go
to my vias code it seems like I am
mapping the state correctly from UX so
let me look and see if it's in the view
X dev tools may be u X and in my base
state I don't have anything in my base
state so let me see why nothing is in my
state if I go back to this code so I'm
pulling in the store from here so I
think the only thing I'll have to do
here is just delete this old file
because now it should look at the
relative path store which is now a
directory and since I'm not specifying a
file it's going to look for the index.js
file and I'm exporting as default the
store from there so let me go back to
the browser and refresh great now it's
working and I'm getting the appropriate
pets so now I'm going to do the same
thing for dogs so I'm gonna take this
actually the whole computed here and go
to dogs and I'm going to add the
computed object here and I also need map
state to connect the view X state from
the store to this component and I'm
going to map dogs here and I'll get rid
of dogs in data perfect so now how do I
figure out whether it's a dog or a cat
in the pet component I could set this up
a few different ways but for right now
I'm just going to put slash cats here
I'm going to turn this into another
variable and because this isn't in my
dog's component I'm going to copy all of
this and come back to dogs instead of
the end here I think I missed the
template oh yeah
that's actually important so I'll come
back do this and I'm gonna close the
table here and I just need to change
this to dogs now in my router I'm going
to have to change this to store the
species and then the ID let me just make
sure that's working back in the browser
now if I click on one of these it takes
me to the species and then the ID and
now I can access these from my component
so back in my pet component I'm going to
say this dot route actually because I'm
in the template I don't need this so
I'll just say route dot and believe it -
params dot species and then duplicate
this row and dot ID let me see if that
works
so back in Firefox and it does work as
the species and the ID now quick way for
me to get to the right cat in this
component is to pull in the cats and
dogs from state because this component
is its own view and it's not connected
to cats or dogs so I'm going to copy the
script tag here and then modify it
I have map state which I want and I'm
going to add dogs here so I can listen
to cats and dogs from here and I just
want to mention real quick that you
could do this same thing by saying cats
adding as a method here and then
returning something like the
stat store dot state cats and this is
actually the same thing as doing map
state here but you're never gonna see
this in an application this is pretty
much the standard syntax it's shorthand
and it's easier to do because sometimes
you have a lot of elements on state and
it's much easier to just use the map
state method and now I have access to
these in my Dom so what I want to do is
find out if it's a cat or a dog and then
display the information here so I'm
going to make a method for this real
quick methods object I'm going to call
it pet pet and inside of pet I'm going
to check for first this species so I'm
gonna say that animals equals actually I
need this here this dot route to params
dot species and now this will either
return cats or dogs and so I want to
access it on my this object so I'm
actually going to pass it in as a
variable if this is confusing to you
then it's the exact same thing as
accessing these arrays off of state so I
could do this cat or this dogs but I can
also use the bracket syntax and pass in
a variable here so I could pass in this
dot cats which is exactly what I'm doing
right here get rid of that and now I
have my animals here and on my animals I
want to see which animal I want to
display I'm just using an index right
now so it's easy if I was using an ID
then I would have to search through the
array and find the animal with the
correct ID so for right now I suppose
I'll just say animal and then pass the
index
of the animal which will be route params
ID so I can do this dot route de params
ID here and that should get the correct
animal and now I'm going to return that
animal and I should be able to use it in
my Dom so let me see if this works and
instead of all of this I'm just going to
have animal dot name go back to my
browser see if I don't have any errors
but I do oh yes property or method
animal is not defined of course because
I called it the wrong thing so the
method is called pet so I actually have
to get rid of animal here and I'm
calling it pet and then I'm returning
animal from here so this should return
the correct animals name and let me
check it back out in the browser and
great
so now if I click on let's say KitKat it
shows up with the correct name of course
this is a little bit messy and I don't
want to be calling the method every
single time I want a property off of
this animal so what I can do is in data
I can put animal and set it equal to an
empty object and then here instead of
methods what I could do is put a
lifecycle method here so I can say for
example when the component is mounted
get rid of this and now I can set this
dot animal equal to animal which will
set animal on my data object and then up
here I will be able to access animal dot
name and let me wrap animal name in an
h1 let me close my h1 and I'm gonna add
the animals age here as well so animal
died H close the P tag and I think I
have a breed property so let me just add
that one real quick - so animal dot
breed now I'll go back to the browser
also so these are old errors I can just
ignore them now I have the name of my
pet the age in years and then the breed
and this works if I have dogs as well
now I could probably put something to
denote whether it's a cat or a dog here
so I think I should take this species
and I'm going to add that in here and
I'll put it inside parentheses and then
I also want a label for the animals age
so here's old and for breed I'm going to
put
this I should have this here too for age
I can put here and that should look a
lot nicer and now when I go here I can
see I have labels on these and I can now
see if it's a cat or a dog
great so another thing we probably want
to do is be able to edit these animals
to add crud operations and that will
lead into how to use actions and
mutations in the store so let's jump
back into view X let's start by adding
the functionality to be able to add a
pet to do this we're going to have to
append the new pet to the array in store
to one of the arrays now the pattern
that you'll generally see for doing this
is definitely not updating state
directly because that's what mutations
are for mutations are there to update
State for you and generally speaking you
will call an action that calls a
mutation which update State and a lot of
the time the actions that you call will
be where you're also making API calls
because they're asynchronous so we're
just going to use that pattern of using
actions that call mutations that update
state so in actions I'm going to add an
add pet method and view gives me a
context object here and then I can use
an argument when I call this function
and I'm just gonna call that pet for
right now make this an arrow function
and with context here it has a commit
method on it so I can use commit and now
this will call a mutation for me so I'm
going to need to create a new mutation
and I'm going to call it append pet and
I'm going to append the pet with my new
pet object that's going to be passed
into this function I want to make a note
here that this is generally not how you
will see this being used because context
you own
need the commit message off of it so you
can actually pull that directly off the
object here and this is generally how
you will see commit being used and
remember this object comes from UX and
this pet is the custom parameter that
we're going to be passing into the
function now I'm going to copy this name
append pet and go into mutations and I'm
going to add a mutation called append
pet here again we have two parameters so
the first that view X gives us is state
so we have the application state and
then the second is whatever payload
we're passing into this function so that
would be pet here and I'm gonna make
this an arrow function again and from
here we can mutate or update state so
I'm going to say so state dot whatever
species which is an array so I can
actually push the new pet onto that
array to do this of course I'm going to
have to pass species into this with pet
so here I'm going to change this so that
I'm passing in an object with pet and
also the species of the pet so for
shorthand and because I'm just passing
this straight through I'm just going to
call it my payload which will have
payload pet and payload species and I
can pass this payload directly into my
append pet mutation and from here
I can D structure this and say species
and pet and state species which will be
cat or dog and I'll push the new pet
onto that and that should append to
either our cats or dogs arrays so I'm
going to do this for cats and dogs at
the same time so I'm going to go to home
and add a button here with a bootstrap
class of BTN and I think BTN primary to
give it some color I'm going to say add
new pet and this should toggle and add
new pet form and now in my JavaScript
I'm gonna add a methods object and say
toggle pet form and this dot pet form
equals the opposite of this dot pet form
and of course this is going to be a
boolean so I also need to add a data
method and return an object of my data
variables and one of them of course will
be pet form maybe to be more explicit I
should say show pet form so it's obvious
that it's a boolean and to start off
with I don't want to show this pet form
so I'm going to say it's false and then
every time that this method is called it
will toggle the form from showing so now
we actually need the form and for that
I'm going to copy a view bootstrap form
and I'm just going to take this most
basic form at the top and then modify it
so I'll come down here and copy
everything in B form
go up B form and now back to the code
going to add that form here that looks
good and I have to of course update all
of these functions because it's not
going to run right now so get rid of at
reset which I'm not going to use now
show pet form so it will show this pet
form if this variable is true so this
button will toggle it and I'm going to
make a handle submit function for when
the user submits this form which will
eventually call our action right here
I'll add the handle submit function and
for right now it's not going to do
anything so let me just fix the rest of
my form real quick
we want the pets name first and foremost
we don't need an email address for the
pet so I'll get rid of that one and now
this example input group I'm gonna say
pet's name and for the drop-down I'm
going to say species and for options it
will just be an array of cats and dogs
to choose from and that should give me a
good drop-down menu I'll add one more
form group here copy this one and
overwrite the check boxes and I'll say
pets age enter age here and the type
will be a number now here of course all
of these V models I need to update so
I'm going to make a new data variable
here I'm going to call it form data and
it's going to be an object that's going
to model all of my different form inputs
so I'm going to have formed added name
which will start as an empty string and
I'll just give age a default of
right now and species I'm gonna say is
no and let me update these here so form
dot age farm dot species and name is
fine
so I also need to update this to form
data instead of just form form data and
one more form data so our form should be
functional all the way until submit
right now let me just try it in the
browser I have the add new pet button
and it's not toggling the form so let's
see in the view J s dev tools in app in
the home component show pet form doesn't
switch to true ever so let me say true
here and it does show the pet form now I
know where the error is happening I go
back to my code I can see that this
toggle pet form is never being called
because I forgot to add it to the button
so I'm just going to do and add click
here it's a toggle pet form that should
work back in the browser refresh and now
it toggles on and off great let's hook
up the submit button in the JavaScript
here I'm going to import another view X
helper called map actions
and this works in the same way as map
state to do this we need to add map
actions to methods now the reason why we
add the actions to the methods and the
state to compute it is that we are
watching for changes to state and we're
not watching for changes to these static
methods they're just functions for us to
call so that we can get state updated so
now I'm going to pass in an array and my
action was called add pet so I'm mapping
that to my methods and now I'm going to
call it from handle submit and I can do
that by just saying this dot add pet and
then passing it the payload so the
payload is an object that I'm going to
create here it's a Const payload equals
this object and the payload should have
the species and then it will have a pet
object with things like the name and age
now to get this information I'm going to
pull it off of data here so the form
data object
and I can do that by using this syntax
I'm gonna pull species age and name off
of this dot form data and I'll put this
in the wrong spot so take this outside
of that object and now here I should be
getting all of my right information
passing it as an object with species and
pet as the payload and then this will go
into the actions here as my custom
payload that I'm passing through to
mutation and the mutation will have
species and pet pulled off payload so I
can update state cats or state dogs and
push the new pet let me see if this is
working in the browser I'll refresh this
add pet we add Bosco and he's a cat
submit okay so if you notice the page
refresh here it was pretty quick but
it's not actually going to submit the
form correctly because of that refresh
it's handling it in the default way when
it's supposed to be submitting a form to
a server but of course that's not the
functionality that we want so I'm going
to come back here go to home and now for
our submit handler I'm just going to add
dot prevent and if you remember this
modifier is just like calling event dot
prevent default just like you would in a
regular function submit handler but this
is a shortcut that view has so I'm going
to come back to the browser and now if I
add a new pet cat the age is 22 and I'm
gonna submit this and I think it's
submitted correctly but of course we're
not clearing out the form after so
there's no feedback whether or not is
submitted so let's go to cats
we see a cat is appended to the table
awesome now I just want to clean it up a
bit and clear out the form when I'm done
I'm gonna see no it's clear now but I
wanted to clear right after I submit to
give some user feedback so if I come
down here I'm going to add something to
reset the form after submit so I'm gonna
say that this dot form data equals an
object and I'm gonna reset it to exactly
what it was before these okay now let me
try to submit another pet this time I'm
going to submit a dog 12 submit and now
it's resetting the form after it's
submitted and let me go to dogs here and
it correctly added the dog of course
there's a lot of other things we could
add but that's basically how view X
works is that you'll call an action from
a component and actions are asynchronous
and then from the action whenever you're
done doing what you want to do with the
action you call a mutation and then the
mutation update state and then whatever
components are listening to state
because you're mapping the state to a
computed function those components will
update in the Dom where it's needed now
I want to show you real quick how
getters work there is actually another
object that goes into the store and it's
called getters so getters are like
computed properties but for your view X
store what does that mean perhaps you
want to pull state into a component but
you want to modify what the component
receives while you're pulling it so it
won't actually update state but it will
get back something that you want out of
state for example we could count how
many animals we have in our arrays in a
getter and then call that getter it from
everywhere we want to get the number
of animals so let's just create that
real quick I need to first create a
getters object and a getters file and
it's the same as the other view X object
so I'm gonna export default in object
here and I'm going to call it animals
count which is a function and here I'm
going to have access to the state and I
can do whatever I want with the state
before I return it to a component
another arrow function and if I want to
get the total count of both cats and
dogs I could say something like state
dot cats dot length plus state dogs dot
length and now to use these getters I
need to put it in one of my components
so I'm actually going to put this in the
home component and I'm going to put it
just above the button so I'm going to
say animals count here but of course I
need to map this so there's another
method called map getters and I need
this inside the computed because we're
watching for changes on this so I'll put
map getters here and this is using the
spread operator as well so that's the
method with an array the same format and
that will be animals count let me make
sure I got that right
and almost count animals count perfect
let's see if that works in the browser
if I go home and I see I have eight
which is exactly how many animals I have
because I have four cats and four dogs
but of course pulling this from a getter
didn't update State at all it's just
modifying how state is seen by a
component so I can run whatever function
I want
now one common thing that you'll be
using getters for is for filtering so I
can say something like get all cats now
to do this I'm going to need to create
another
I'm going to need to create another
array here and this time I'm gonna call
it pets so instead of cats and dogs in
separate arrays I'm going to give it one
array cats and dogs if you haven't seen
this syntax before it's basically so
that the array is flat because if I just
put cats and dogs without the three dots
behind each it would come out being all
of the cats in one array and then all of
the dogs in another nested array so this
is an easy and nice way to make all of
the pets together in one array so now
that all of the pets are together here
I'm going to need to add what species
they are inside the data to
differentiate between the two so I'm
going to add species is cat now I'm
going to copy this and just paste it in
all of these
yeah one extra comma and I would put
this in dogs too but just to show the
getter example I'm going to say get all
cats will be returned state dot pets
which will have both cats and dogs in it
and then dot filter the filter method
takes a function which will give us each
pet one at a time and allow us to return
just the pets we want in an array so I'm
only going to include the pets in the
array where pet excuse me pet dot
species equals cat and now I should be
able to use this get all cats getter
well once I add state from my component
and I'm going to do that here so I'm
going to say add another variable get
all cats and I don't want to print out
all of those objects so I'm just going
to put lengths to see how many cats is
returned and of course I need to add
that inside my getters get all cats and
now I should be able to call this from
the Dom and check how many cats are
returned versus the total number of pets
back in the browser
I see it's getting the correct number of
cats versus all pets in case you can't
see there are four cats and eight total
pets that's basically how getters work
it's used a lot for filtering or making
changes to what's going to be rendered
on the Dom you can do a lot of different
things with getters you could also pass
in other getters so here I could
actually call another getter inside this
getter because view X gives me that as a
second argument this whole system is
pretty simple once you've practiced it a
little bit I want to show another thing
that I think would be helpful in a
production application or as
building your personal projects that is
setting up sass inside of a project and
this is how I generally do it in view so
I add a folder inside of source slash
assets called sass and then I have an
index dot sass file and I make a couple
folders inside of my sass directory so I
have my components and my libraries and
my global Styles which I usually call
base and then I import all of these
files into my index so I'll import first
libraries and then base and then I'll
import components here so inside of the
libraries folder
I might have mix ins or material design
or whatever other sass files I want to
import here I can also import CSS files
I just rename them dot s CSS because any
valid CSS can also be used inside of es
CSS files which is a type of sass file I
just prefer to use indented syntax
without curly braces or semicolons and
there are some extra shortcuts that you
get with the indented syntax that I like
so after the libraries the base files
I'll generally have something called
variables that sass and now this
underscore is just a convention in sass
to mean that this file is imported into
another file and not compiled as an
individual file so I have a variables
file and here I might do something like
set my fonts as a variable so I could
set let's say main font
and set that equal to I'm not sure how
medica if that's right or whatever a
Google font that I've imported or any
other font and then sans-serif and do
colors and padding and spacing I'm just
gonna do maybe a blue color here which
could be zero zero zero zero three four
and then you get the idea you can put
pretty much anything you want to be able
to use in other parts of your
application and then you can just change
it in one place and this also makes it
easy if you're doing different themes or
letting a user choose their theme in
their application you just save all the
different themes here and then attach
them to a class and toggle that class
dynamically from the JavaScript inside
your view components so now that I have
some variables here I can import this
into my main sass file and within at
import I'll say base slash variables and
I don't need the underscore or the dot
sass on the end it's going to look for
either dot sass or dot s CSS files and I
think this makes the file look really
clean it's easy to look through a whole
list of these now in the components let
me just pull up one component here let's
say a view and my home view and it
starts out with the class home but
generally I don't think this is
descriptive enough so I usually call
things like home view container or
something like that in my project and
this is a wrapper class so that I can
contain my nested classes and they don't
affect other parts of the application
because my global styles will all be in
base but each component that I make will
also have its own styles so I'm going to
create a new style file for the home
component and then I put this wrapper
class
and then any other classes that I want
to affect the home component I'll put
nested inside of here just so you can
see the nesting I'll put four spaces
instead of two which is generally what I
use whenever I'm doing something like
python or SAS using indented syntax
because it makes the indentation easier
to see so now I'm just gonna say color
and use my color variable that I'm also
importing into my index file so now in
components I will at import base slash
home and now I have styles that are
specific only to the home component so
how do we get these styles to apply to
the components you have to import them
into the main J's file so right below
where I have these bootstrap files
imported I'm also going to import from
the assets folder sass and index dot
sass and now that should apply all of my
sass files to my project because if you
remember when we created this project
from the view CLI we chose sass as the
preprocessor so the vo CLI set up all of
the sass processing for us and being
able to compile it to CSS and things
like that which makes it really easy to
use sass inside of projects so it's
complaining about this at import
statement so let me add components here
and now it's working fine although the
text is not turning blue let me see why
that is if I go to inspect element it is
actually blue but it's just so hard to
tell because it's not a very bright
color so let me change that to a
brighter color if I go into the
variables and I'm just going to change
this to any color not necessarily blue
just so it shows up I have no idea what
color this is
okay purple and it doesn't affect any
other page here because I am using a
namespace in sass so it only affects
anything inside of this class which is
specific to the div wrapper around home
dot view so hopefully that makes sense I
do make usually one of these components
for every single of my component files
and any global Styles I'll put inside
various styles in the base directory so
that's enough about sass I just wanted
to show you how I usually set up a sass
project this code will all be online if
you want to see it I want to change one
more thing that feels a little bit dirty
about this project and that is to pull
this table out into its own component in
my components I'm just going to create a
new file called pet table dot view and
I'm going to use this as a table inside
both cats and dogs so to start this I'm
going to just steal this template put it
here and to make it unique for each one
we're going to need to pass in some
props to this component from both our
cats and dogs views so I need to have
props on my default object I'm gonna
make this an object and say first of all
I think we're going to need a species
which will be a string and then here I
can replace this with species it's gonna
be a lower case and here I'll replace
this with pets because we'll pass either
cats or dogs as pets and pets will be in
array and then here I also want to use
species to dynamically pass that and I
think that's it really we just have to
import pets table let's import it into
cats fur
so I'll import pets or pet table from at
components slash pet table dot view and
I need to set it as a component I'm
gonna use in my Dom here components pet
table not sure if I mentioned this
previously in the video but using pet
table as a component here I can do this
in two different ways I'm gonna get rid
of this and I can use it capitalized or
view gives me another default way to do
it which is kabob case by default to
make it more HTML like I could do that
generally the recommended way that I've
heard from members of the core team and
others and also from using it myself is
to just keep it capitalized and that
lets you see the difference between the
custom components that you create and
the other HTML tags like div so I'm
going to be passing in the species here
and I know the species is cats so I
don't have to do anything else to that
and I'm also calling for the pets or the
cats which I need to pass in and I have
that array here mapped through computed
so I'm going to pass that in using V
bind as pets pass in the cats array of
course this is kind of confusing because
these have the same name but this one is
an array because we're using V bind so
view is looking for a variable so it's
actually pulling this variable cats
array off of computed and sending it in
as pets
now species we're not using V bind here
so it's just static so it's the string
cats and let's see how this works if we
go to the browser and go
to cats it's still working the same way
so I'm going to copy this for dogs go
here into the dogs component and get rid
of all this table stuff here except
we're going to be passing dogs in for
both of these and then we need to pull
in the pet table component from here and
also add that component so that we can
use it in the DOM and I'm going to add
it here and then it should work still
for both cats and dogs refresh and it
works for dogs just as well and we can
still see that we have the correct
number of both being pulled in so that's
all for this view tutorial if you're
interested in going further with you let
me know and I might make a more advanced
intro to view in the future here are the
resources I think are most helpful for
getting into view first there's the
state of UJS which is a yearly report
put out by Evan you who's the creator of
you he gives lots of great talks about
how the project and library are evolving
every year and you can find those for
free on YouTube another resource I
highly recommend is somebody who's the
senior view developer called the jerod
will Kurt he live streams various
tutorials mostly about view every
Thursday night at 7 p.m. Eastern Time in
the USA he's a really great teacher so I
highly recommend jumping into some of
those chats and asking him questions
then there's one of my favorite people
on the view Jas core team Sarah Dresner
now I didn't cover animations in this
tutorial but she's actually the best
person to talk about those types of
things
UJS has a lot of great built in
animation features I'm going to link a
video of a talk she gave on view
animations that I think is really good
one last thing I recommend for getting
into view is checking out the views on
view podcast you can find it on
dev chat TV or on overcast or any of
your other favorite podcasting
applications thanks so much for watching
this whole tutorial I know it's kind of
long but I hope you got something out of
it if you have any questions or feedback
from me you can find me on Twitter at
Gwen underscore Faraday or shoot me an
email at Gwen Faraday at p.m. Emmy I
also have a youtube channel called
coding with Gwen that I'm going to be
starting back up here soon and this is
kind of a kick off video for that so if
you are interested in more of these
types of videos you can check me out
there thanks